[Music]
good evening I am mr. work the
ambassador to your deepest desires let
me officially welcome you to Fantasy
Island
we were all just discussing how this
works exactly ah you will know soon
enough and I promise you will not be
disappointed
the island has two rules there is only
one fantasy per guest and - you must see
your fantasy through to its natural
conclusion no matter what well why
wouldn't we because fantasies rarely
play out as you or I might expect but
they always play out exactly as they
should not even you know how they're
gonna go only the island knows I am but
it's humble story obviously the fantasy
won't be real but that's why we go to
horror movies and ride roller coasters
right feel something I'd like to think
that this is more exciting than riding a
roller coaster mr. Sullivan do you mind
giving us a privacy I need to give miss
Cole instructions no it's okay he knows
about Sloane I'm owning it okay and the
lobby
there is an elevator inside push the
button for the floor with no name
can I record it with my phone so I can
remember it it is your fantasy this is
just for me but it's called Fantasy
Island for a reason
place where anything and everything is
possible you say what you didn't say is
how mister were tailors it's fantasy
specifically to the guests based on a
one-page questionnaire I will confess
I'm relatively new here soon how mr.
Rourke does what he does is as much a
mystery to me as it is to you what I do
know is that your life is about to
change forever
I'll be ready
there is an elevator in the elevator you
press the button to the floor with no
name behind those doors the life you
always tremble
[Music]
the planet but here
this weekend you will be our guest
here anything and everything is possible
no service it's not everything is
possible
good evening I'm mr. Orrick let me
officially welcome you to Fantasy Island
[Applause]
I'm curious how this all works what if
your fantasy involves a person from your
life Holograms like to buck what if it's
somebody who died Tupac so what's your
fantasy revenge on a childhood bully at
the your life is about to change
[Music]
that is really good holiday there is
only one fantasy per guess and you must
see your fantasy through no matter what
oh my god that's really hurt this is not
what I meant
what the hell is this place
people died here the islands twisting
what we asked for
weren't brought here to have our own
fantasies we were brought here to be a
part of something else
I'm your friend
[Music]
[Music]